Speaker 1: Well, it begins.
Donald Trump paid zero in taxes in 2020, claimed
a $5 million refund.
And the big picture of Trump's taxes that
has come out.
Based on a report we have, we don't yet have
the tax returns, but we have a report about
the tax returns from the House Ways and Means
Committee is just about everything that we
suspected, everything that we suspected, and
we're going to talk about it.
So let's start with the big picture data.
Let's look at Trump's income.
Taxable income and taxes paid over the last
six years.
In 2015, Trump reported an income loss of
nearly $32 million paid, had zero taxable
income and paid $640,000 in taxes in 2016.
Trump says he lost $31 million, had zero taxable
income and paid $750, not $750,750 in taxes.
2017 Trump claimed negative income of $13
million, paid $750 in taxes.
In 2018, Trump claimed a taxable income of
23 million and paid about a million in taxes.
On that 2019, Trump claimed about $3 million
in taxable income and paid a little over 100
K in taxes.
And then in 2020, Trump reported a loss of
nearly $5 million and paid 0.0 in federal
taxes, claiming a refund of $5.47 million.
There's a good CNBC write up called Read How
Much Trump Paid or Didn't Pay in taxes each
year.
It outlines the numbers that I just mentioned
with a number of other elements, including
that the tax returns we are ultimately going
to get are redacted.
And it may actually still be difficult to
figure out how Trump got to these negative
income claims, etc..
The most important thing that I think is is
worth mentioning here is that most of this
stuff is almost certainly legal.
And what we're really getting to here is the
failure of the IRS, despite all these claims
that the IRS is predatory and they've got
all these armed people, which they really
did, there are very few armed people.
And it's not a big deal that some of the people
are armed.
Despite all the claims about the IRS, the
IRS really has failed us, not even auditing
Trump in his required automatic audit that
presidents get until they caught wind.
That Richard Neal in the House Ways and Means
Committee was trying to obtain these tax returns.
Then they said, Oh, we'd better do that audit
on Trump, which we were supposed to have done
already for several years.
So a few different aspects to this.
Is it possible that Trump's taxes will expose
crimes?
Absolutely.
They look like they would be along the fraud
lines stating different asset values for the
same assets, depending on whether he's trying
to avoid property taxes or personal taxes
versus get a loan using those assets as collateral.
We already suspect.
And in fact, we know based on what the ruling
with Trump's business of 17 guilty counts,
I guess it was two weeks ago, we already know
that that was done at the business level,
almost certainly being done at the personal
level.
The taxes will help to build that case.
Are there potential national security issues
as a result of some of the people Trump is
in league with?
Absolutely.
The tax returns could very well expose that.
But what's really important to understand
is that Trump's not the only rich guy using
the tax code in this way and widely speaking,
avoiding IRS scrutiny that would be appropriate
for the relaxed application of the tax law
that Trump and people like him use.
So this is a story about Trump, but it's also
a story about the tax code and a story about
the IRS.
Now, one question that you might have is how
do you go negative close to $100 million over
five years in income and yet still live the
lifestyle that Trump lives with day to day
expenses being so lavish and expense of the
private plane, all these different things.
If you lose 30 million in a year, how do you
also have a private plane and all this stuff?
The answer is that you are asset rich.
You are asset rich.
And you can also, we don't fully know because
we don't have the full tax returns yet, but
you can borrow against the assets to have
money with which to live that lavish lifestyle.
And again, it is not unique to Trump.
If anything good will come of this, it's that
the Trump tax returns will expose the mechanisms
that many rich people use in order to live
lavish lifestyles, but pay almost no taxes
or in some cases, no cases, no taxes at all.
You tell lenders that your assets are appreciating.
Dramatically.
And then they'll give you girth the huge loans
against those assets, which you can then use
to live your lavish lifestyle.
You tell the IRS these very same assets are
worth nothing.
I lost money on these assets.
Let me take a loss on them.
Give me a tax refund.
That's very generally speaking, the name of
the game.
Then you live off of the loans.
You use the lot.
The lies to the IRS to claim a negative income
while you're actually making millions and
then you get a tax refund as well.
Now, if Donald Trump is actually as rich as
he claims to be, these tax returns don't really
make it look like Trump is super rich.
If Trump is really as rich as he claims to
be, there's almost certain, certainly criminal
level of fraud and avoidance that's going
on here.
The other possibility is Trump isn't actually
nearly as rich as he claims to be, and we
may or may not find that out.
The reason Trump clearly fought so hard to
keep his financial records from becoming public
is because he seems to be the fraud.
He seems to be not, not quite or nearly as
rich as he claims to be doing really sketchy
stuff with asset values.
We've given you the full list before, but
the really important takeaway is it's not
just Trump doing the stuff.
And there's a question as to whether it's
the tax code or the enforcement.
That's the problem.
And I want to talk about the IRS component
next.